foreign
talk to the great Nicole what's up
Nicole
hi I'm so excited to talk with you today
I'm excited to talk to you what's up
okay I just want to say before I start
that you've helped my marriage in so
many ways
like every day my husband gets home from
work and he'll literally ask me what new
thing are we gonna try from that
processed meet man today
it's been you've been amazing so thank
you you're welcome but listen you can't
be like
when you're mad at him you can't be like
well Dr John says that you can't do that
you promise
I promise you do I could tell you don't
I totally have don't weaponize me I
already have enough people who don't
like me that's fine all right I'm gonna
be walking through Boise one day and
he's gonna be like hey we got a problem
and I'm not that tough I'm not that
tough all right so how can I help you
today thank you thank you for thank you
for being in our gang and first saying
kind things that really makes it's
awesome
um so my question is how do you know
when it's time to find a new job or if
you need to do more trauma work or
change your lifestyle
well I think it depends yeah
you're you're what I'm a kindergarten
teacher
now I really do love it I love my kids I
love the act of teaching but I am really
struggling with living in this like
constant state of fight or flight during
the school year
um
let's back at a trauma therapy what are
you scared of what's your body reacting
to in an eighth in a with a room full of
kindergartners
um
I've been physically hit in my classroom
I've been spit on
um and so it's that aggression
is your school one of these increasingly
um I can't even wrap my head around how
insane this is that and I know it's
five-year-olds like I know sometimes it
doesn't matter that doesn't matter that
doesn't matter
um
what matters is you have an
Administration that will remove those
kids from from the learning environment
correct will they
no or they will for a moment and then
they're back
after they calm down and have a laffy
taffy or whatever it is with no
intervention
correct yeah here's what's here's what's
happening all across the country and
it's going to keep happening because of
the coward
cowardly
an insane way
School administrators and school boards
are are setting up teachers to be abused
screamed at yelled at spit on hit at all
levels
because they will not remove troubling
kids from the learning environment and
they are destroying the learning
environment for every other kid in that
room
and so I'm going to tell you you're not
safe in there and let's be super clear
if those kids are doing it they're
coming from homes
where that that kind of is either
tolerated or that kind of behavior is
picked up
right yeah it's learned somehow so I'm
telling you if you're my wife
who my wife was a teacher forever and
that's that's her world and she said I'm
tired of getting spit on and hit by kids
I would say quit today
and I need you to hear I need everybody
listening I need you to hear me say I
dedicated my life to Educators both my
phds come out of a College of Education
that's what I love that's who I am
um I love spending time with
administrators I love spending time with
schools I love spending time with
teachers that's my world I married one
for God's sake I love that crew and
I'm not gonna subject a group of people
to insane violence to insane all-day
everyday disrespect a disrupted learning
environment
um
because people are too cowardly to take
on obnoxious annoying parents I'm not I
just can't I can't good conscience say
well you just gotta tough it out honey
yeah you know what I mean now if you're
wired for it
some people are
like Bring It On
if you're wired for it what you have to
do is the work outside of the classroom
so you can be well so you can go back in
right right I think that's what I'm
having a hard time with because I mean I
love the kids so much and I'm good at
what I do it's taking me a long time to
be able to say that out loud but I'm
good at it good good the kids deserve
that but it's hard because I my body I
shut down whenever those things happen
I would be willing to bet you money you
shut down
bigger you shut down before that
what's what's a bigger shutdown
I don't know
because um the great there's there's an
extraordinary book I recommend everybody
read it it's called burnout by
um Emily nigotsky and her sister I think
it's Amelia nagotsky
um it's it's excellent and it's written
to professional women but I think men I
got a lot out of it and I've recommended
it to men all over the place too
um but they still burn out down into
three areas the feeling that number one
nothing I do matters
I can come at six a.m and tutor I can
come at six a.m and help these kids
learn how to count I can come at 6am and
clean up the room I can stay till 7 PM
nothing I do is gonna change these kids
lives nothing's going to change the
system nothing's going to change
anything
second one is this deep and profound not
tired it's exhaustion
it's in your bones right it's this
overwhelmed when I pull into the
driveway I of so School building my body
starts to shut down because it can't
handle what's coming
and then the third one is
I think the most damning one is is this
increased isolation it really starts to
siphon off other people from you and
it's isolated isolated isolated isolated
yeah I could see that because I get home
and I just I don't want my husband to
touch me I don't want to talk to him I
just want to go to bed which then your
body starts yelling I need connection I
need connection I need connection
yeah and then it runs out the door and
starts this whole process over again you
see I just that spiral spins Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter
yeah I see that so when I'm talking to
First Responders when I'm talking to
people who like
or emergency electricians they got to be
up at 2 A.M hanging from a
a poll fixing electricity so a whole
neighborhood block can can have Heating
and Cooling right
um what I tell them is you have to have
to have friends not in your industry
that you hang out with on a regular
basis
you have to have regular intimate
contact with your husband or your wife
you have to put on calendar
you have to be safe in your work
you have to deal with the fatigue and
often we think dealing with fatigue
means doing nothing it's usually the
opposite I have to start an exercise
program
I got to start honoring my body with
what I eat
I've got to start and you you think
right now like I couldn't possibly move
and go to the gym after the day I would
tell you that would transform your life
um my buddy Sal de Stefano with the Mind
pump guys he's told me that when he was
a personal trainer people used to
um sign up for personal training with
him
and they would skip because they didn't
have enough they would say I don't have
the energy today
and he would say you're paying for it
and they would come and they would come
and they would come and he said within
six months to a year they would cycle
off right so they would see it have a
trainer and then not have a trainer then
have a trainer then not have a trainer
he said he'd get a call from these
clients and they would say hey
I'm out of energy I gotta start working
out again
because they realize that energy begets
energy that the path towards a body
feeling like it can handle more is
movement and exercise you might be a
crossfitter I don't know you might be
running marathons I don't know
definitely not I just know because my
community has been teachers my whole
career that when you go to work at 7 A.M
and you deal with 30 people running
around everywhere and an administrator
that's running around everywhere and
um no support and angry emails from
parents that your school district
expects you'd respond to every 14
minutes and by the way get off the
computer but why aren't you responding
these you know all those things that
they get home and then they collapse
and then they grab something to prop
them up unhealthy they grab another
drink they just Netflix themselves out
and that starts a cycle of
right and then your body just says hey
I'm out yeah I don't want this life
I think the biggest thing is I've
noticed I'm just so much happier since
we've been
off I just feel
light and happy and yeah and so my
question to you would be
can you recruit like what are you doing
to feel light and happy
because you're doing different things
it's not just the absence of
what are you doing
and it can you put that into practice
for your school year can you be
responsible for some new boundaries
meaning I leave at four
ta-da I need you to do all this work
unless well I I leave it for
then we're just gonna have to yep you
might have to but I don't do 12 hour
days
yeah right I do not I do not have kids
that spit on me they're not welcome in
my class
and that's something I guess I have a
hard time like I'm I'm allowed to say
that like I think I think at some point
teachers have to start saying that or
the entire education system in the
United States is going to implode on
itself
yeah yeah and I know that's a huge
burden for you and you don't have to
carry it and if you're not going to
carry it I applaud you but you got it
you gotta get out of that job because
you're not safe
yeah
part two is I'm having our time 6 we're
trying to get pregnant and so I'm
worried about even if I do get pregnant
the stress on
tomorrow's worries be thought through
tomorrow
yeah that's a tomorrow thing
what I would like to see you do is build
a life worth living
and let your job be a part of that not
try to survive the life you've created
because of the job you have
and so I'm going to send you a copy of a
brand new book it's called building a
non-anxious life okay
okay and it's got six choices that you
and your husband can make together
on building a non-anxious a non-burned
out a non-chronically stressed life
and as a part of that we all have to
work I would be willing to say work is
important we're not designed to just sit
home and collect checks that's why their
whole country went crazy
when the government said 300 million of
y'all are not essential we'll just send
checks y'all stay home we went crazy
we're not designed to not have a purpose
and a role and so
work hard work is a part of that
dangerous Adventures are a part of a
non-anxious life but they have to be in
the right context and you have to have
connection and community and safety and
health and healing and all these other
things
so that you have Bedrock to Anchor into
and you can repel off and do the hard
job
that makes sense you see like it inverts
everything that we're told about how to
do I just quit this job maybe
Maybe
but I hear in you you love it
I really do I love it and you're really
good at it
and you see these kids and you are the
first other adult many of these kids
have ever interacted with besides their
parents or their grandma or whoever and
you're real real good at it
just getting exhausting
so maybe before you quit you sit down
and you back all the way out you say
okay how can we build a life
so that I can both go do my job well
and when we get pregnant
and have a bunch of little Knuckleheads
running around that I can be a great
connected mom there too
and if I choose to stay at home when we
have kids great we're gonna cross that
bridge when we get there that's not
today
it's not today
and let this be like for every
administrator every principal every
teacher every school board member
you have to make the learning
environment a safe place and I don't
mean safe in the Wawa I can't hear
things I'm uncomfortable with that's not
what I'm talking about at all I think
that's insane and nonsensical too
what I'm saying is if a teacher's
getting hit or spit on or cussed at you
have to remove the kid from The Learning
environment period and I'll go this far
I don't care if that kid has trauma or
has reasons for acting out as a child I
fully understand that I've dedicated my
life to sitting with those kids but they
can't be in this environment because
they don't have the tools to be there
they need some support and help and
burning the rest of the learning
environment to the ground and running
every teacher in the country out of
their job cannot be a part of the
solution
it can't be
God is something different guys we gotta
do something different
because great teachers like Nicole are
heading out the door and we cannot have
that I got two little kids in public
school I got a vested interest in this
please let's solve these challenges